Ralston College and the Cambridge Center
for the study of platonism,
it's an immense honor to introduce two
of the foremost intellectuals of our
age.
These thinkers,
wonder,
philosopher,
the other psychologist.
A spiritual writers is addressing the
malaise of the soul in our culture.
John Stuart Mill in his magnificent test
say on Coleridge roots of Benton.
Jeremy Benton,
who above all others,
men that have been led to ask themselves
in regards to any ancient or received
opinion.
Is it true and by Coleridge,
what is the meaning with Coleridge in
contrast to the utility of Benton,
the very fact that any doctrine had been
believed by thoughtful men I'd received
by whole nations and generations of
mankind was part of the problem to be
solved was one of the phenomena to be
accounted for.
This I think is true of both Roger
Scruton and Jordan Peterson,
and I'd like to mention just a couple of
points of convergence.
Warmed is an insistence on the
importance of imagination as conversion
to truth in opposition to a mere fantasy
and the opposition to idolatry ideology
as well as idolatry,
especially the idolatrous ideology of
the Post Modern for call derived
consensus and the urgent return to
questions about truth,
beauty and goodness,
and of course part of this is linked to
what both perceive as the perilous
position of the modern university.
They both argue with that continuity of
esteem needs to be regained in the
humanities and the dominant strands of
the humanities are leading to an
impoverishment of the souls of students.
Narratives both argue are not just
stories of power,
but these narratives persist because of
that truth,
so the importance for both Ralston
college and indeed for the Cambridge
Center,
for the study of platonism,
of both of these thinkers is their
insistence upon the relationship between
mythos and logos,
between story and reason,
the insistence upon a hierarchy of
values and their vision of education as
conversion to truth.
This conversation will be moderated by
the president of Rolston College,
Steven Blackwood.
Thank you Douglas Fir those inspiring
and grounding word starting us off,
right in relation to the
past that we wished to recover.
That'd be a start,
I think with a very straightforward but
perhaps difficult question.
We're,
we're,
we're gathered around the theme
apprehending the transcendent loosely to
gather this conversation.
I'd like to begin by asking each of you,
what is the transcendent?
What does it mean for something to be
transcendent?
Well,
let me start that.
I,
I take a position which I attributed
also to can't,
that,
um,
that we have a very clear negative
understanding of it.
We were advanced to the edge of our
thinking in so many areas knowing that
although there's nothing further that we
can say that somehow the truth has never
nevertheless not run out of that
negative view,
I think needs to be
combined with a more positive view,
which tells us that there are other
ways,
not just,
not maybe not thinking,
but some other way of,
of crossing that boundary and does it,
were landing in the realm of the
transcendent and knowing it from inside.
I think that this is something that we
understand very quickly when personal
relations in that when I,
when I address you,
I know that I'm addressing something
which addresses me too,
but from a place where I could never be,
I couldn't at myself from those eyes,
um,
and I can't capture the thing that is
looking at me from those eyes,
but nevertheless there are leaps of the
imagination which can put me in your
point of view and from that point who I
can come to understand exactly what I am
but in a completely different way from
simply the ordinary empirical knowledge
that I have with myself.
And I think that that sort of
interpersonal understanding,
I would say we can adapt to all the
other aspects of our world,
which is mysterious to us.
A music for instance.
With that,
that's a beginning of.
And I want to return to music a bit,
a bit later,
Jordan.
Well,
I think it's useful as an adjunct to
that.
So,
so,
so roger mentioned that the transcendent
is what we bump up against when we
realize our ignorance.
And so it's that which transcends our
ignorance.
And that in itself makes it an
implacable fact,
unless you believe that you have no
ignorance,
in which case there's no point in
furthering a discussion with you,
um,
so the transcendent is the fact in so
far as it's that which transcends our
ignorance,
but you can also think about it
technically so and,
and,
and I think we know enough about how the
brain works now so that not that we know
much so that useful things can be said
about that
you tend to represent the world in the
simplest manner that you possibly can,
that works for what you're doing.
And so you don't actually see the world
you see sufficiently useful,
low represent low resolution
representations of the world.
And if they work then that's fine.
There's no need to adjust them and
they're relatively easy to remember and
to manipulate.
But now and then you have a
misapprehension about someone let's say,
and you have a conversation with them
and the conversation goes sideways.
And what that means is that the thing
that you thought you were conversing
with is not the thing that you're
conversing with.
And that manifests itself in error,
right?
So error is the place where the
transcendent reveals itself and what is
actually revealing itself is the reality
that's outside and underneath your
perceptions and so what you see in the
world in some sense is a set of animated
cartoons and a lot of that is actually a
consequence of you seeing nothing but
your memory because your brain is
organized so that instead of going
through all of the difficulty of having
to look at the thing and that in itself,
you look at what you assumed to be there
and if you can get away with that so
much the better,
but the thing in itself is always much
richer,
richer than your apprehension of it,
which is partly why you make mistakes,
but also partly why you can continue to
garner wisdom in the world.
There's always more there than meets the
eye and God only knows how much more
there is there than meets the eye.
And you can show this even in the
religious sense to some degree,
because you could say that there's an
element to the transcendent that
instills people with a sense of
religious significance.
You can do that by immediately,
scientifically,
by feeding people chemicals,
for example,
that disrupt the inhibition of
perception by memory.
And then that puts them in a place where
the transcendent tends to reveal itself
sometimes an overwhelming force.
So this is not some fiction that this
exists.
It's the,
what's transcendent is more real than
the reality that you perceive.
Well,
let's pick up.
Let's pick up on that because the,
the,
the ancients and medievals had a clear
sense that it wasn't the world that was
changing.
It was we ourselves,
as we make an ascent towards deeper
truths,
higher forms of the beautiful,
uh,
as we ourselves become more self
conscious.
So it's not the world that's changing.
Uh,
but,
but us,
I'm wondering if you could say how you
understand the nature of that ascent,
that,
that movement and what brings it about.
Uh,
I would
be a bit wary of the metaphor of ascent,
you know,
uh,
I,
I think in Plato is quite clear what he
meant.
He wanted us to actually to transcend
our earthly perceptions in the way of
seeing things and look on the world from
a,
from a God's eye perspective.
Um,
and this could be done if we enter the
world of the pure forms,
uh,
and so on,
leave empirical reality behind.
I think actually
insofar as the experience of the
transcendent that I,
as I understand it,
is available to us modern people.
It's not that way that we get it perhaps
about some Jordan might be right.
That,
that,
that there are these drug induced
experiences where things open up to us
because old barriers of suddenly swept
away.
But in my own case,
it is the concentration on the empirical
reality,
which at a certain point flips from mere
sensory understanding,
took to a vision in that of it's
communicating something to me,
and I think this is what the literature
and art and music to,
at their best they read,
described reality so that it is actually
communicating something to you.
It's not just there as an inert object
before you,
uh,
and that sense of the transcendence is
like discovering yourself in the mirror
I'm seeing in the world as a whole,
that thing in you that you could never
identify in words,
you know,
the subject which is looking at it.
I'm a,
and it's not a mystery mystery,
but it's something that you can then
explain the difference.
A good writer and a bad writer,
of course,
it's such a good writer will describe
something in such a way that the thing
described has the soul of the reader in
it.
Um,
so,
so that might be a distinction in part
between the thing and the meaningful
thing.
Right?
And that's a,
that's a very mysterious phenomenon.
In fact,
in some sense that the essence of
phenomenon,
because that means to shine forth is
we're surrounded by empirical facts.
They're everywhere.
There's more of them than we can
possibly count,
but some of them do emerge and manifest
themselves as that,
as that conjunction between the factual
and the meaningful,
and then that's what's gripping and if
you're fortunate.
I mean,
to me that's also partly what what leads
us onward.
Maybe in something approximating the
asset that you described is that the set
of facts manifests itself as implicitly
meaningful and that means in some sense
that there is a call to you that he
hasn't from within you.
I mean,
I don't know how else to put it exactly
because you walk into a bookstore and a
book will will,
will reveal itself to you.
You know,
or or you have a conversation and part
of the conversation will trigger
something in you or you're reading a
scientific paper and much of it's dull
and then all of a sudden there's
something that sparks outward that's
like a port that's a portal into the
transcendent.
And that is a place where the fact and
the meaning converge,
and that's a phenomenon we don't
understand very well.
It has something to do with its
convergence,
with the narrative that drives us,
whatever that happens to be.
Yeah.
That's so good way of putting into
actually it connects with the general
problem of what the humanities are in
the university.
But I've,
I've always assumed that in some way or
another,
if you're teaching literature or
musicology or,
or history of art or anything,
you are opening young people to those
moments when the world ceases to be a
mirror accumulation of facts and as it
were,
addresses you and um,
that requires literary criticism.
It requires opening yourself to
experience in a way that,
um,
it requires serious education of a,
of a special kind.
And I think that if we thought that the
humanities as directed towards that,
we can see why they might be one way to
fill the moral void that,
that grows so easily in people's lives.
So young had this idea,
which I really love.
It's a very sophisticated idea.
Um,
it's,
it's this idea of how the self,
first of all,
so the self for young,
this Christ was a symbol of the self.
So the logos was a symbol of the self.
So that's sort of what would you say?
It's the divine essence of humanity and
the image of that is a symbol of the
self and for young the self was the
totality of the individual across time
and space.
So it's whatever you are as,
as a transcendent object.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And then can imagine that that
transcended object also has to interact
with you and the world moment by moment.
And his belief was that those times when
that space of meaning opened up,
so there is that convergence between the
fact and the gripping of the fact was
the manifestation of the self which is
this transcendent object in this
specific moment of time and space.
And therefore our call forward to move
towards revealing that totality as much
as it can be revealed.
And so it would be partly and that would
be partly revealed by then following a
meaningful pathway.
And it would be the case that if you're
engaged in the teaching of humanities
and literature,
that you are trying to engage exactly
that part of the person.
It's to pull them into the story and to,
and have that open up to them.
And then that's a portal.
It's not,
it's not words on paper,
it's a,
it's a portal to their,
to their further development towards
this,
the manifestation of this higher and
more transcendent motive being
the Hindu idea for the transition from
the to Brahman,
isn't it,
that you've suddenly pass through a,
uh,
a barrier that can't actually be
described because you can only know it
when you're on the other side of it.
But when you're on the other side of it,
you looking back at the thing that
you've left and seeing it in as it were
for the first time.
And knowing what it means.
I guess that's a little connects a
little bit with what Douglas was saying
about,
about courage.
That courage was an advocate of a form
of education,
a form of knowledge which shows the
meaning of things as opposed to the mere
facts accumulated by Bentham and people
like that.
Both of you have done quite deep dives
into 20th century totalitarian
ideologies at both of you have been a
very trenchant critics of the etiology,
the various forms of nihilism in,
uh,
in our own culture.
Um,
but I think all of us tire of,
of,
uh,
I kind of negativity that has come to be
very prevalent in our culture,
not simply the nihilism,
but then we can criticize the nihilism.
We ought to criticize it.
Both of you have been,
had been brilliant critics of it.
Um,
but I,
what I take to be at work in both of
your,
uh,
in,
in the work that both of you do is,
is not fundamentally criticism but a
turn towards something positive,
a recovery of a sense of the
transcendent.
I'd like to have a,
have a turn for a moment to what does
that recovery look like?
Where do we start?
Well,
if we're thinking intellectually world
of scholarship and education
that we both belonged to,
has turned,
as you say,
in this negative direction,
always preferring debunking explanations
of everything,
show reducing them to the lowest motive,
uh,
that,
that it's not truth,
but par that we pursue in all that food
codian nonsense.
And I think the only response to that is
to come up with bunking explanations of
so to speak.
Try to put back into the subject matter
of one's own inherent belief in it,
and to recognize that,
uh,
you know,
we're not around on this earth for very
long and we do have an obligation to
find the things that we love and not the
things that,
that we reject a under those things that
we love the view,
the best way towards them is to look at
the things that other people have loved.
That's what a culture is.
It's the residue of all the things that
people thought were worthwhile to
preserve and teaching that will will
again reconnect us to what matters.
Well.
And there's,
there's also ways of,
of,
of providing a pathway forward by making
the food.
Kalia and arguments,
let's say about power,
more high resolution and one of the
things that I do in my lectures,
public lectures that I think is rather
comical is to take and poke fun in some
sense about the idea of power as the
fundamental foundation for the
hierarchal structures of the West.
I think,
well you can think of the West as one
large scale,
low resolution,
totalitarian tyranny,
the tyranny of the patriarchy.
Or you can decompose that and which in
some senses to transcend the concept.
And I think,
well,
I,
I asked my audiences what they think
about the tyranny of plumbers or the
tyranny of massage therapists.
Well,
because it,
it,
it's,
it's dead relevant.
It's like,
let's say you need a plumber and you do
need a plumber.
Everyone agrees that you need a plumber
and because there's hell to pay
otherwise.
And so,
and then the question is,
well,
how is it that you go about selecting a
plumber?
And the answer isn't that there are
roving bands of tyrannical plumbers that
go door to door telling housewives that
if they don't use their services,
the surface of the most tyrannical
plumber,
that they'll be mafia like consequences.
What happens instead is that you look
for the plumber who is most able in your
estimation and in the,
in the,
uh,
in his reputation as distributed through
the community for being able to fix
pipes and run a business and engage in
an honest transaction with you.
And that's competence.
That's not power.
You see,
what I see as most corrosive about the
postmodern types,
especially those who've derived
themselves from let's say,
is that the idea that every hierarchy or
the hierarchy as such is predicated on
power,
is actually an assault on the idea of
competence itself.
And that in turn is an assault on the
idea that there are real problems that
can actually be solved.
Well then if you dispense with all that
and it's only power,
there is no real problems to be solved.
And there's no noble ways of solving
them even even as in even in as
concrete,
a manner as a good plumber would solve
that which is a not,
not a trivial thing.
And so then you deprive people of you
deprive people of that have that sense
of purpose in their life.
Even even at the high resolution levels.
You know,
and I've insisted in my lectures that
you know,
if you're the sort of person who runs a
small diner,
that it's incumbent on you to run the
highest quality small diner that you
possibly can because what you're doing
there is not merely providing people
with basic nutrition.
There's way more to the space than meets
the eye and your noble.
What would you say?
Acceptance of your limited
responsibility is also simultaneously a
way to transcend that.
And that can be a place where the
neighborhood meets.
That can be a place where tired people
revivify themselves before they go off
to do their difficult work.
That can be a place where you can mentor
your employees and help them develop
their life.
Like it's a rich.
It's an unbelievably rich microcosm.
And to take on the,
the care and tending of that microcosm
as a responsibility is also a great
pathway to meaning and unnecessary and
meaning is something that's,
well not EPA,
phenomenal and not dispensable,
but absolutely central to human
thriving.
And in the psychological and practical
sense.
Yeah.
But we do have to try and understand why
it is that there is such a charm in the
food codian position.
Why is it that people want to believe
that all the best things.
What we think of the best things in
human relations simply disguised forms
of manipulation.
You know,
that uh,
the,
the whole feminist view of the
relationship between men and women,
for instance,
switcher is founded on this deep myth
that men are exercising exercise power
as a agenda to use the fashionable
world,
the word over over women.
And that all study of this is just a way
of revealing the power and the,
uh,
and the competitor is through which it
flows.
You know,
I think there's a,
a will to believe this and why is,
is one of the big questions that I think
we try,
we have to try to understand is it that
when people lose some kind of
transcendental religious faith that they
are automatically fall into this pit of,
of resentment as a of the Nietzschean
unkind to try and find a,
the,
the oppressor in every relationship or
is there a,
are there truths and exploring as well?
Is there other forms of power or forms
of human relation that looked like power
from one aspect but perhaps also looked
like tenderness and dependence from
another aspect and that they've just are
emphasizing one half of it or something
like that.
I think there are real questions as to
how it is our culture has got into this
position.
Yeah.
Well that's the question below the claim
of power.
And so I mean,
I've,
I've thought about that to some degree
and here's three possibilities.
I mean,
one is the accusation that all there is,
is power is the justification for use of
power of cool.
That's,
that's handy.
If that's what you want to use,
so then then there's another problem and
that goes along with the failure,
the willful failure to distinguish
competence from tyranny and power,
let's say,
because we might think of power as
unearned authority,
something like that because we need a
definition of power and I think that
there's a resentment at work there
that's very,
very deep.
I think it's,
it's deep in the biblical sense which is
that there is a proclivity for those who
do not manifest what they could manifest
in the world and thereby fail to watch
the success of those who do manifest
what they could manifest in the world
and succeed and become embittered by
that tremendously embittered and then to
label that as power and then to attempt
to destroy it because it's simpler to do
that than to do the radical internal
retooling that would be required to set
things straight internally.
I'm sure that
that's right.
Uh,
that,
that's one explanation of why people are
always tempted by the zero sum vision of
relations.
He's benefit is my cost sort of thing.
Yeah.
Oh,
I wanted to pick up on that the,
the,
the very widespread view that things are
zero sum,
which is of course the,
the,
the language of power.
What's the antidote to that?
What is the,
how does one overturn the,
uh,
the ideology of power?
How does one transcend that with a non
zero sum a truth or approach to life?
I
personally would say that the first
thing to recognize is that there are
positive sum games.
You know,
that's what the real theory of the
market tells us,
that there are whole realms of human
transactions where both parties gain,
uh,
from,
from the shed,
uh,
engagement.
Uh,
and um,
though that doesn't work,
drive away,
the real source of this is difficulty.
Um,
it has something to do with what Jordan
was referring to and you know,
that people's,
people's resentment at the success of
others when they cannot match it or
cannot easily match it will or will not
match it,
which is either.
Yes,
yes,
exactly.
Uh,
and of the Labor of,
of re reconceived and your own position
in such that you actually have to do
something about it.
You know,
that it's,
there is some,
something lazy about the zero sum
ambition,
uh,
but uh,
it's not,
uh,
you know,
it's not a vision that successful people
have,
you know,
and that they have at any level of
reality and you can actually combat that
to some degree by make it high
resolution again by,
by making examples.
It's like because very few people
actually believe once they observe that
all the relationships they've had with
other people have been zero sum.
Now you might get some very
disadvantaged people and these people do
exist who've been taken advantage by
virtually everyone they've ever
encountered in their whole life like
that does happen.
But most of the time all you have to do
is remind people.
It's like,
well,
think of someone that you loved.
Even briefly think of a friend that
you've had.
It's like,
well,
you,
you successfully negotiated with that
friend to do things together because
otherwise it's not a friendship and it
has to be successful negotiation,
which means your friend has to be happy
with what you were doing and you have to
be happy.
And so,
and then wasn't it the case that you
were both happier doing that than either
of you would have been doing something
else alone and,
and isn't that evidence in your own
action and your life for the existence
of non zero sum games and they're
dependent on successful negotiation is
we can both have more than we would
otherwise have if we can come to a
consensus about what will both pursue
and it's very few people when you make
it personal like that.
And,
and high resolution.
Again,
it's very few people who are willing to
pursue their ideology of zero sum of a
zero sum reality so far down that
they'll actually use that to
characterize their most intimate
relationships.
Now I would say that someone who does
that by temperament is literally
psychopathic because the psychopathic
view of the world is absolutely that.
It's a zero sum game.
Yes,
I think that's right.
But of course we have a whole body of
literature,
um,
about sexuality,
which is trying to establish that the
sexuality is the exercise of power of
one person over another.
You get it already in south was being
and nothingness where he almost is
almost by logic that,
that a serious sexual desire for him
ends up as sadomasochism because you
cannot extract from the other that gift
of his freedom,
uh,
which,
which is what you're looking for because
his freedom,
his,
uh,
not to be obtained by you and therefore
you can only do this by who sort of
tearing that his flesh and getting him
to confess in the extremes of agony,
but he can't do it.
You know,
this kind of thing.
I know that's a very good vision of what
sexual relations are,
but you get a that image used
by Simone de Beauvoir and all kinds of
feminists to essentially to de
legitimize the idea that there is such a
thing as love for the other sex.
Well,
there's,
there's a,
I think it also masks and more
fundamental problem that's really a
biological problem.
Like it's a misapprehension of a genuine
problem.
But part of what sex does is temporarily
subordinate the individual to nature and
the species.
And so there is a domination there,
you know?
And,
and if,
if a,
if a woman decides to have a child,
then she is going to undergo a series of
extraordinarily radical transformations
and she's also going to end up in this
situation where in all likelihood
something else becomes fundamentally
more important than her and there.
So there is a,
there is a sub,
it might be voluntary,
subjugation,
subjugation to nature,
and,
and that's built into the fabric of
existence.
And I think it's very easy not to want
to grapple with that because it's such a
profound problem.
And then to make that a secondary
consequence of something like unbalanced
power,
relationships between the genders,
but of course a traditional religion
offers you selves for this,
the rites of passage in which,
which joins men to women,
the right of passage which makes birth
unexperienced with the whole community
and death.
Likewise,
uh,
and um,
you know,
the sense also in these great events,
one is occupying a position in the,
in a moral space that has been occupied
by generations before one.
And so on.
This normalizing of these huge
transitions I think is something that
that we have is depended upon religion
to provide this a sacred and having
taken that away well or ignored it or
trying to live without a exactly,
without the idea of a sacrament and
we're actually at a loss when these
great transitions occur.
Just because it is the case.
In fact that to to engage in the
integration of sexuality with your
individual life is a series of
sacrifices.
So for example,
if you get married,
that's a sacrifice because it's a
sacrifice of all other people and so
it's a sacrifice of that possibility and
then to have a child is the sacrifice of
all the things that you could have done
otherwise.
Then having that child and two but two,
two,
as you pointed out,
to make that part of a broader tradition
to say that,
well that is a sacrifice and there is a
loss that goes along with that.
But what you gain as a consequences of
if immeasurables significance in
contrast to the loss.
And one of the things that's really
struck me in this lecture to her that
I've been doing,
so I've been in about 100 cities and one
of the things that I've been talking to
people about is his meaning and I
suppose it's meaning in relationship to
the transcendent and the necessity of
meaning as an antidote to suffering and
malevolence.
And the hypothesis is something like,
well meaning is to be found in
responsibility.
And this is a,
it's a revelation to people because they
haven't conceptualized it that way
before.
It's like meaning isn't,
um,
it isn't happiness and it isn't self
esteem.
And it isn't momentary pleasure,
isn't any of that.
It's,
it's the,
it's the bearing of a sacrificial
burden.
And that that actually works to enrich
and ennoble your life in ways that make
the tragic element of it tolerable and
had to keep you from bitterness.
And so these things that are put forward
as subjugation,
like the subjugation of women to the,
to the catastrophe of birth,
let's say,
or even the,
the indignity of,
of Patriarchal Union is all of a sudden
something that you can take on as an
aspirational goal rather than something
that's a mere imposition on your,
on your moment to moment freedom as a
relief to people to hear that and to
know it.
Of course.
No,
I agree with that.
But there is also the sense that in the
world in which we live,
where obviously people have been
detached to a greater extent from the,
uh,
any continuous religious tradition,
there still is a sense of loss.
A people,
uh,
they don't.
They know that they're missing something
but don't know quite how to identify it.
And that's one reason for thinking,
for them,
thinking that it's been taken away.
Something's been stolen from them and
they look around at the people who are
at ease in the world,
unsuccessful and seem to be a,
I'm on good terms with themselves and
think of them as the ones who done the
stealing.
Uh,
and that is a dangerous attitude and I
think it's,
well,
it surely that is part of what he rubs
in all these
strange academic disciplines like gender
studies,
which simply have as their goal,
the undermining of the existing order
without anything positive to put in its
place.
And I don't know what those,
those academic studies recruit people
all the time from this fund of,
uh,
of a,
of isolation as the sense your sense of,
of loss without an ability to identify
the thing that's
last as the cold lake element of them
because they do,
I would say to some degree,
degree prey on people whose
interpersonal relationships have been
irreparably damaged.
I have a hypothesis about,
about the feminist end of the postmodern
radical leftist movement.
So,
and this is something I've talked about
much in public but,
but.
Well,
but here goes,
this should get me in lots of trouble.
So,
so,
and,
and there's a variety of things that are
tangled together here.
So we don't know how female biology
would manifest itself politically.
Male biology does.
Female biology is going to.
And that's because female political
activity on the largest possible scale
is a relatively new phenomenon.
So,
so,
and it isn't obviously the case that men
and women's views of the world are going
to.
Precisely.
So here's a hypothesis.
You're telling me what you think about
this.
So one thing that a woman really wants
to know about a man,
or perhaps you might say one thing that
femininity wants to know about
masculinity is that it's not a predatory
tyrant.
Okay?
So,
and here's why.
I mean,
first of all,
there's fragility and feminine sexuality
to a greater degree than there is an
male sexuality because women bear a
higher price for sexual misadventure,
let's say,
and are perhaps more prone to
exploitation by force.
But more than that,
part of being a woman is having the
possibility of bringing something
extraordinarily fragile and vulnerable
and valuable into the world.
And the first concern might be,
are you a predator?
Fundamentally,
And so what I see happening in the,
in the feminist disciplines like gender
studies,
is the politicization of that
accusation.
And the accusation is prove to me that
you're not a Predator like in in your
fund,
in the fundamental element of your
masculinity,
not only historically but now,
because the cost of you being a Predator
is,
is too high.
Now I feel that that's an inappropriate.
I think that's what's driving the
demolition of the idea of presumption of
innocence.
For example,
we'll start with presumption of guilt
and prove to you will be proved to me
that you're innocent.
And I think the problem with that isn't
that there are no predatory men because
there are plenty of predatory men.
The problem is is that the courageous
way to deal with the problem of the
Predator is to offer a hand in
courageous trust and to invite forward a
partner from the monster that's the.
That's that mythological manner in which
this is supposed to be undertaken.
The courageous,
a courageous part of the woman's
journey,
let's say,
is to face the monstrosity of a man and
to invite out of that something more
noble to emerge.
And there's courage in that ingenuine
risk.
And I think that that's for gone in the
accusation process.
And then the,
the other element of that seems to me to
be that,
well,
if you are a Predator and irredeemable
in your predatory nature,
then the best thing to do is to render
you harmless.
And if we're going to obscure the
relationship between competence and
power and assume that all of your
striving upward is merely a
manifestation of power,
then what we'll do is we can do as much
as possible so that harmlessness can
replace virtue.
And I see all of that driving these
resentful disciplines in there.
And their aim is the ems escalation with
the men.
Yeah,
that's the evil queen.
Yeah.
Because we have the evil king,
right?
That's the tyrannical patriarchy.
Well,
the evil queen is lurking somewhere.
Yes.
So
the program is it.
A lot
of this is true,
but I'm a society does not seem to have
the capacity to put that to one side and
set up rates the normal.
The fact that most men and most women
are not like that and that there is,
there is a,
a natural desire and need of the sexist
to love each other,
to be united and to create children and
so on,
and that,
that,
that the old stability that that was
built upon this has gone.
So I mean that,
uh,
nobody wants.
Nobody in the intellectual world wants
to celebrate that.
So,
so I,
I just,
I had this interview a few a month
ago or so with a woman from Gq and she
was fully onboard the,
the predatory male train,
let's say.
And you know,
when people like that interview me,
they start talking about the patriarchy
and I say,
well,
I don't believe in the patriarchy.
I don't buy that conceptual structure.
What's so interesting,
and this has happened more and more over
the years as they've developed this,
first of all,
the person that I would be talking to
had some idea that it was hypothetically
possible to reject the idea of the
patriarchy.
But now when I say I don't believe in
it,
it's,
it's that idea is meant with stunned
disbelief.
It's like,
well,
what do you mean you don't believe in
the tyrannical Patriot that everyone
knows?
That's true.
And and I think,
well,
so here's your hypothesis.
So this is the hypothesis is that
throughout history,
the fundamental relationship between man
and woman is one of parasitism and
exploitation.
That's it.
And so,
and that's the case,
I guess until 1960 and the publication
of the feminine Mystique or something
like that,
but that's the entire course of human
history that when the,
when it seems to me that the appropriate
story is that men and women labored
mightily under their terrible
constraints for,
for uncounted centuries cooperating
together by and large to,
to build some modicum of security and
freedom and stability so that they could
raise children and have a somewhat
harmonious and productive life and all
of a sudden it's become not only
questionable to put forth that as a
proposition,
but somehow tyrannical in,
in,
in essence just for positing it as a
reality,
but the spot it because isn't it because
of this peculiar view that the
underlying all of this
as a kind of social structure that this
is being created.
The distinction between men and women
doesn't have it spaces in nature,
it's a basis is in the institutions that
we have created and since we created
them,
we can change them.
That there is,
there's been a sort of a kind of almost
hysterical invasion of everything by the
idea of human choice.
If,
if there is,
if there is a structure to the
relationship between men and women,
then we ought to be able to change it.
And of course,
chain it might mean that I have to
change my sex in order to conform to the
way things are.
But that also has become a choice.
Well,
and is,
is,
is not the very,
uh,
very a constant focus on division,
whether between man and woman or between
left and right to orbitz or between this
race and that race or any other way in
which we might,
we might divide people according to
groups.
Isn't that very polarized,
fractured,
uh,
fractured polarization.
A,
a sign of a loss of a common human
culture of,
uh,
of,
of a,
of a universal plane in which we all we
all are as,
as human beings.
And,
and so if,
if,
if that's,
if that is.
So I suppose what I take to be so very
urgent in our time,
uh,
and,
and I wonder,
it might be difficult to find anyone who
at least when you go down to a high
enough level of resolution as you say,
Jordan would not think this is true,
that we must recover that sense of our
selves as
entities that participate in a universal
and transcendent plane.
That we have a common culture that I see
myself in the other,
as you were saying earlier at Roger,
and I'd like to have both of your
thoughts on what strategies were means
for that recovery.
Uh,
and perhaps we can focus particularly on
the,
uh,
the questions that we started with,
with,
uh,
Art Music you've written extensively in
architecture,
of course,
are our Roger.
And you've thought long and hard about
the humanities.
Jordan,
what does,
what is the character of recovery?
How do we bring that about?
Well,
I'm,
maybe again,
I think that there are reversed what you
have to identify those aspects of the
human condition that move of their own
accord towards reconciliation,
you know,
uh,
rather than a conflict and a and
division of the sort that you're
referring to and we are very familiar
with them.
It's not just that just love,
which of course is something which is a
very complex thing and can't be,
can't be just conjured from the skies,
but there are other aspects of our
condition that we can educate through a
first,
first of all,
through studying examples and then
through imitation and then through a
self discipline.
Obviously forgiveness is one of these
things.
Um,
and the habit of putting yourself in
another person's perspective,
looking at yourself from outside,
uh,
and wondering whether you know,
you are as so seen acceptable to
yourself.
All those,
uh,
you know,
of course,
again,
religion,
the Christian religion at least was,
um,
built upon.
That's kind of intellectual discipline.
The discipline of seeing your neighbor
as yourself and seeing yourself
therefore as Amir neighbor,
and um,
I,
I suspect that you have,
we have to revive those basic moral
discipline's not for,
for the use of people who don't have the
overarching faith,
the belief in the transcendental
judgment to which we will we all called,
but who nevertheless have to be shown
that we do live our lives as an object
of judgment.
Nevertheless,
and here are some guides just read Anna
Karenina for,
for example.
Um,
I know it takes a long time for facebook
addicted youth to read Anna Anna
Karenina,
but there's still hope,
you know,
and,
and they're likely to listen to it if it
becomes an audio book.
So,
so,
um,
well,
because maybe more people can listen
then can read.
I mean,
so,
so let's,
let's think about literature for,
for,
for a bit.
And so now if you read something like a
dusty see novel or Anna Karenina,
you're not really reading the account of
a single person's life.
What you're reading is it like the
author has taken a variety of lives and
amalgamated them in unified them into
something that's like a.
it's like a compilation of lives,
so it's life.
It's like life writ large,
so that's what fiction is.
It's more true than than reality because
just like a mathematical abstraction can
be more real than the thing that it
represents.
In some sense.
The fiction is.
It's like a.
it's like a portrait.
If you sit for a portrait,
you'll sit and the artist will paint you
and then you'll sit again and then
you'll say it again and then you'll say
it again,
and so the portrait is actually a
composite of you,
and so it's got a richness sometimes
that a photograph can't match,
and a fictional character is actually a
composite of many people,
and so the opportunity to read a great
work of fiction is the opportunity to
place yourself in the perspective not of
merely another person like you do in
normal discourse in a mundane setting,
but to place yourself in the perspective
of a compiled character.
So you,
I've experienced that extraordinarily
powerfully with dusty eskies crime and
punishment to put myself in the position
of this student who was nihilistic and
who had every reason to commit murder.
And it's an unbelievably intense novel
because everybody in the novel is hyper
real and we think of fiction as falsity
or,
or as,
as untruth.
And it's not,
it's,
it's abstraction.
An abstraction isn't untruth.
It's,
it's more than truth often.
And so the humanities help us walk
through the souls of others and because
we can imitate and it's one of our
primary remarkable,
miraculous abilities.
We can imitate the compiled characters
that we encounter in literature and
mythology and religion.
And that does help flush us out and
ennoble us.
And we can,
we can.
I just wrote the Foreword to
Solzhenitsyn's Fiftieth Anniversary
version of,
of the Gulag archipelago,
the abridged version.
And I ran across his wish that
people could learn from what he
communicated all the horror and
suffering to put themselves in the
position of both the perpetrator and the
and the accused simultaneously.
And to decide that that's not the road
to walk down.
And so the advantage of placing yourself
in the position of other people is that
if they're good people,
then you can be like them,
and if they're not good people,
then you can avoid that pathway.
And then you don't have to learn that
through,
through the agony of direct personal
experience in the short span of your
life.
There's nothing more,
there's nothing greater than you can do
for people then to introduce them into
those patterns,
stories so that they can gain from the
catastrophes of the past.
No,
I agree with that.
But of course,
uh,
in fiction ones also concerned to
identify if you're writing fiction,
identify with the character in order to
understand that character because it's
not as though
you can,
you can't actually grasp a character
from the outside that you have to be
able to see through his eyes what it,
what the world is in which he is.
And that is,
I think,
an exercise of the imagination,
which I value greatly.
Uh,
and um,
you don't necessarily come to the
conclusion that therefore I don't want
to be like that.
It might be just enough to say,
now I see that,
that,
that that's a possible human being,
um,
and you knowledge of the possibilities
is amplified and your sense and your
ability to position yourself in those
possibilities also,
I think.
Right?
So that's a matter of differentiation as
well as direct.
Yes.
I think sometimes in my more dire
moments that this opposition to cultural
appropriation,
right?
So the idea that I'm not allowed anymore
to imagine myself say fictionally as a
woman or as,
or as a character from another ethnicity
or even to play the role that role as a,
as an actor,
I think that it's,
it's part of the assault on the idea of
the individual and the non zero sum game
because it precludes the possibility
that I can take on the role of another
and,
and understanding manner and actually
facilitated dialogue.
And that undermines the claim.
I would say that everything is only a
secondary consequence of power because
if I can actually bridge that gap,
well then I'm not isolated in my group
or my ethnicity or whatever it is I can.
I can become partly you and we can
communicate and I would say because of
that literature and art is a great
threat to ideology,
especially of the group identity kind.
And of course they're perfectly aware of
that,
which is why the radicals on that side
of the equation are doing everything
they can to,
to a reporter from the New York Times
who wrote a rather scurrilous piece
about me.
She had done the literature degree at,
at Columbia,
a bright woman,
and she told me in all honesty and an
apparent transparency that she had no
idea this is how deep this is.
This has become saturated into our
culture.
She had no idea until she,
until she had graduated from Columbia
that there was any other way of reading
a work of literature except through the
postmodern Lens.
And the postmodern Lens is well,
who are the groups that are being
represented and what power games are at
play and who benefits.
And,
and I mean,
I don't know if because she turned out
to be quite a strange person.
Um,
but,
so I have no idea if that,
if that was a ploy on her part or
whether that was like a,
like a,
a naive,
what would you call confession,
but it's increasingly the case that,
that is how literature is taught in my
home province of Ontario.
The Elementary Teachers,
Federation of Ontario wants to start
teaching literature from a postmodern
critical perspective in elementary
school to demolish it.
Well,
there we,
uh,
I mean I'm in favor of cultural,
cultural appropriation.
I mean,
I'm a product of it.
I,
I appropriated the idea of the English
gentleman and,
you know,
and I'm trying to make myself be it a,
I know it's a Paideia
that's part of doing it well,
but I've understood the world from the
inside and another way.
But in a,
I just wrote a book of stories which was
reviewed,
but,
uh,
somebody who says,
you know,
this,
these stories make cultural
appropriation into a virtue.
So I felt good about that.
They,
they begin with a,
an inside view of the psyche,
of a,
uh,
of,
um,
a terrorist,
have an,
uh,
an Arab terrorists who,
who's,
who has a legacy of vengeance and,
um,
who is a failure and
who's lost.
I tried to make real in the,
in the feelings of the reader as he,
as he reads it.
And um,
uh,
and then the subsequent stories show the
same kind of loss in completely
different people.
So
I wanted to bring up that a book of
stories,
actually a souls in twilight by Sir
Roger Scruton,
a series of five short stories of five,
I think is it five short stories each
which are our portraits of a character
at a certain moment in time.
I think it's safe to say Roger,
that they're all tragic stories in a
sense.
What I found,
so moving about those stories is that
these are individuals in states of
dislocation,
anchor lists,
seeking depth,
meaning truth,
stability,
uh,
and yet in their confusion,
in their darkness,
willing against that very thing that
they seek,
or you might say violating.
We're transgressing that sacred thing
that they're longing for.
That's not what's beautiful about the
book.
Um,
uh,
what's beautiful is that in the reading
the reader,
her or himself comes to a sense of what
that longing is for positively a sense
of the,
the stability of love or out of home or
have relationship.
And,
and,
and I suppose what I want to ask
following up on this is that that seems
to be a profoundly redemptive vision
that you have in that,
in those beautiful stories,
Roger,
at that,
that it's showing the persistence of the
beautiful and have the good even in its
absence,
that I can read that story and have a
perception of what positively I am I am
looking for and just try to refer to
something that you say in,
in one of your books,
Jordan,
that,
that even through an experience of,
of evil one can develop an apprehension
of what the good is.
And wondering if you could each say
something about the,
that you know,
either either there is our reality to
these transcendent things where there is
not the condition did either just a
construct,
goodness or beauty and truth or they
have a transcendent.
And,
and sovereign,
persistent re reality.
And I'm wondering if you can each say
something about the,
the persistence or sovereignty of these
things even amidst our darkness and a
suffering.
Well,
I,
I would say that in tragedy when tragedy
Israeli effective,
uh,
there is a redemption offered in this
through suffering the,
the,
the we,
we encounter the possibility in tragedy
that a human being can through the most
noble motives also
bringing on down upon himself
destruction.
And uh,
this destruction is no different from
the destruction that's going to affect
all of us in the end anyway.
But here is somebody who,
who has faced.
It's down in some way that his Nova,
who's ability of nature and his ability
to go out towards others in a condition
of,
of love and reconciliation has not been
taken away from him.
And the spectacle of that is all the
more intense because nevertheless,
the death intervenes and takes him away
as it will take you and me away.
But without having had the chance to
reveal a nobility or even to acquire it,
you know.
So I,
I think that for that reason,
it's very important that in literature,
a noble characters are seen in a
condition of loss sometimes that,
uh,
and their,
their redemption comes because even
though they've lost what we all must in
the end lose,
there is that in which is struggling
towards reconciliation with their own
condition and with others,
it's the sense that they are living as
another and not as a self.
You know,
that's,
I think it's a crucial thing that see
the Gulag archipelago is often viewed as
an endless documentation of the horrors
of the Soviet enterprise.
But it was an investigation.
It was an experiment in literary
investigation and that isn't what the
book is about.
The book is about Solzhenitsyn's
observations of people in those terrible
situations who did not contribute to the
terror and who transcended it and the
unbelievably power,
powerful impact observing that had on
him and the personal transformation he
underwent as a consequence of observing
those people and the decision he made
because of seeing them in their
ultimately tragic circumstances
transcend that to to to transform his
life from the bottom up and to write
this great book and to reveal the utter
catastrophe of that entire ideological
movement and so you deal see the light
most clearly when it's super imposed
against the darkest possible background
and so and great literature which polls
people way down into the depths and in
in this,
in this compiled,
fictional manner.
Then it also does at the same time
highlight what's what's.
What's the opposite of that?
So I it by reading of
of your,
your,
your work,
both of you.
There's an implicitly theological
character here and we can't speak about
the transcendent in a certain sense
without being theological at it.
Why is it that we can't just delights,
just can't be completely shut out.
I mean,
if,
if evil and darkness,
we're the sovereign principles as a
human,
as it might say,
metaphysically,
well,
they could,
it could just be all delights,
could just be completely blackened and
yet that's not what we see.
And I'm wondering if you would each
comment on the,
what you take to be the,
I think what,
what might,
what might be a theological articulation
of the facts on the ground?
If the facts are that you can't shut the
lights right out,
that there is still there.
What,
uh,
what's going on there?
I totally agree with what Jordan said
about the Gulag archipelago.
Um,
and that goes back to just ask is,
uh,
from the house with the dead.
You know,
his accountant of being in Osiris,
much milder,
we've kind of imprisonment,
but nevertheless it was almost a
vacation home in comparison.
No,
I agree.
But nevertheless,
he described these characters who for
whom,
that everything has been taken away.
But he also notes that in each of them I
can find the spark of God.
Something which Janacek repeated when he
made this into the,
into that wonderful Libretto for his
opera and,
and Yana check tractor show in music.
How these derelict characters will
suddenly shine with that,
with that light from another source that
doesn't come just from what they are in
those circumstances,
but from something higher.
And I think,
um,
you know,
I would say one is always obliged to use
metaphors when we get to this point,
but it is true that,
that you can find in someone even in the
most deprived and desolate
circumstances,
that home which you can blow to co two,
caused a spark once again to,
to light up inside him.
And that is as far as we get to meeting
God.
But,
um,
there is no reason to think that we need
to get any further in my view.
Um,
that's what everybody saw in Maximilian
Colby when he offered himself in,
in the,
in Auschwitz for,
you know,
to sacrifice why he was,
um,
a canonized.
Suddenly you see that there is something
else in all of us in which in the
circumstances,
however severe and deprived will will
shine from with a different light and
make those circumstances worthwhile
because they produced that light.
It couldn't be,
in some sense the mercy of God that
keeps him hidden from us because if you
imagine that your sacred duty is to blow
on those embers that you described,
even among people who are in desolate
straights.
Then every time you fail to take that
opportunity,
then you tell things badly towards what
they shouldn't be tilted towards.
And it could be that the revelation of
your inadequacy in the face of that
moral duty,
which would be in some sense equivalent
to an encounter with God would be enough
to tear you into pieces.
And so maybe you get glimpses of that
now and then because that's,
that's all you in your current depraved
moral state could stand of seeing of the
face of God.
And I think there's something to that
that's similar and says things to that
effect.
I think.
Yeah.
And um,
yeah.
So I often heard in the old communist
days when I used to travel around
Eastern Europe and,
and meet people who are in really dire
straits,
safe,
said similar things,
you know,
that,
um,
that God would reveal himself.
But,
uh,
in these circumstances,
the revelation will be something too
strong.
What I could bear.
That's a beautiful image you've given
us,
Roger,
of blowing on the embers within blowing
on the embers of transcendence.
Um,
I'd ask you both about the forms of
culture and institutional life that
produce that blowing on the embers in
the individual.
It seems to me both of you have a very
deep sense of the dignity of the human
individual,
of the individual's connection to the
transcendent,
the grounding fact of our existence.
What would be the forms of culture that
we would say to be necessary or most,
uh,
most inclined to foster in the
individual that blowing of the flame?
I think the most accessible form for,
for most people is music and music to me
is the most representational form of
art.
Because I think that the world is made
out of patterns and we perceive some
patterns as objects,
but fundamentally it's patterns and what
you want is all the patterns of the
world to interact harmoniously in,
in something where every element is
related,
intelligibly to every other element.
And I think that when your life is in
harmony,
that you can feel that.
And when you're dancing to beautiful
music,
you're acting that out.
It's the music is,
is the,
is the music of the spheres,
and you're participating in the
powdering of your being in accordance
with that structure.
And that gives you an intimation of,
of transcendence.
And,
and it's not criticizable.
That's the thing that's so lovely about
it,
is even as our society has become more
cynical and more self destructive and
more deconstructionist,
the power of music has in fact grown
because it speaks to that eternal
harmony and the reality of that eternal
harmony in a way that mere intellect
cannot deny.
And I mean,
I've was always amused.
I went to this show,
uh,
the ramones,
a punk band from New York.
It was the loudest concert I'd ever
heard by by a good factor of 10 in my
ears rang for like three days afterwards
and there were all these like nihilistic
punk rockers all crammed into this
theater and below me.
There was a mosh pit and it was like
ants on a frying pan.
They were just smashing into each other
and throwing people around up above them
and it was quite rough and they're all
having this beautifully transcendent
musical experience which belied all of
nihilism and it was and they absolutely
thrived on it.
It was like,
and even the lyrics were harsh and
nihilistic,
but it didn't matter because the music,
even if it's rough,
even if it's in its rough form,
was something that united them in the
sense of this like pattern beauty and
brought them together and so exposure to
music that's people die without music.
It's like music is everything.
I mean it's not everything but I beg.
It's everything about the beauty of this
particular experience
I think actually don't see it as an
extremely important phenomenon.
It partly because traditionally dancing
was dancing with someone.
The width has been taken out of dancing
and uh,
the head bashing and so on that goes on
with heavy metal and the right is
dancing against someone,
you know,
the,
the wideness of the dancers.
I think there's something really.
We see it in Scottish reels and things
like that where the whole community is
dancing in an orderly way,
recognizing that their need for law and
order and taking pleasure in it.
And I thought,
I find that a very near to a
transcendent experience.
Um,
I,
I feel a kind of narcissism has crept
into the dance with,
through recent forms of dance music,
but I mean,
that's my old geezer
or,
or his or his.
Um,
or is it simply to say that there,
that,
that the principle itself is sovereign.
It everyone thinks about the logic,
for example,
of,
of Dante's inferno,
um,
uh,
which has ever more degraded forms of
knowing and loving,
um,
that,
uh,
that the,
the mechanism of the nature of you might
say the nature of the soul is the same
at the top of paradise as it is at the,
at the bottom of inferno,
but it has all these infinite gradations
of wholeness.
And so I don't think we have to say
that,
that the,
the mosh pit is,
uh,
is,
is equivalent as a work of art to,
to Beethoven or,
or Palestrina or Janacek,
but rather than perhaps what's going on
in,
in that is nonetheless a longing for the
pattern and the recognition of the other
that you,
you say
yes,
but your original question was how do
we,
how do we,
a coax people back into the,
into a life which is based on the
recognition of the other rather than the
gratification of the self.
Because that's essentially what we're
talking about with the
today at least.
And I,
I would say teaching people how to help
others.
Uh,
the role of the teacher,
is it very dignified one,
he's only so if the teacher actually
thinks that he is helping the pupil to a
body of knowledge that he has access to
and that sense of helping other people
is a very rare thing and it's,
it's made more rare by the,
the welfare state and the ready
availability of subsidies for a
subsidized life without leaning on any
particular person,
you know,
uh,
and I think,
um,
relations of dependence are actually
very positive if they're accepted on
both sides,
you know,
and I think,
um,
something that we don't teach the boys
scouts movement and all that they used
to teach a young people these things
teach people how to go out and help
those who needed them and how to make
those little day to day sacrifices.
Um,
and eventually through the process of
imitation and imagination,
a character grows based on that.
I feel that there isn't any obstacle to
this.
It's a very simple form of education.
All of us can do it.
And all of us who have children do it.
I'm sure Jordan does it with his
children the same as I with mine.
Of course,
you know,
you're always disappointed.
They always go away into the corner with
the,
with their wretched little iphones and
so on.
But nevertheless,
um,
it,
some of it rubs off and you know,
that in the long run they will be
capable not just of finding love,
but also of offering forgiveness and
working for rick reconciliation.
I don't think in a sort of narcissistic
culture which is propagated by the media
and by the universities,
uh,
that,
um,
that they're being pointed in that
direction.
That is true.
But then it's up to us to point them in
another direction.
I think as an academic,
we talked already about that place where
the meaning and the fact are conjoined
and that's the proper place to lecture
from because people who lecture
constantly make the presumption that
they're there to deliver a set of facts.
But there's an infinite set of facts.
And so at the very least,
you have to select the facts and there's
a mechanism that selects the facts and
what,
what you want to do as an academic is,
is tell your students through,
through direct discourse and also
through action about something that
you've encountered that you've fallen in
love with and to,
and to communicate the love that you
have for that,
the love for literature and,
and not to say,
well,
you should read this book,
but to say,
well,
here's this book and here's what it can
open up for you and this is how it does
it.
And,
and this is what you'll gain from it.
It's an inestimable gain and there's
some struggle in it.
But,
but there's a,
there's something it that's of,
of,
of unbelievable utility.
And you have to believe that in order to
communicate it.
And then that's.
So that opens one of those doors,
you know,
and maybe some students will step
through that and think,
well maybe that sounds like something I
need.
I'm in this dire situation and I need
something.
I need a life raft.
I need to.
It needs something to boy me upward and
it's gonna.
Take some effort obviously because
nothing worthwhile comes without effort
to communicate that commitment you have
to these two,
these two,
these phenomena,
the phenomena that we already talked
about to beauty and truth and to
literature and entered the classics in
the humanities.
It isn't enough to to say what they are
and to transmit them.
It's to.
It's to manifest yourself as a living
part of that tradition and to end to
show yourself thereby as a model for
living out as much as you can,
what that tradition represents,
and to show that that's so much better
than like a short term pleasure seeking
nihilism,
that they're not even in the same
conceptual universe and people are far
more open to that.
They know already.
People know,
especially when they're hurt.
They know that happiness is fleeting and
that suffering requires a sustaining
meaning.
Everyone who's lived knows that and so
to say,
well,
here's some bomb for the suffering and
it's profound and deep and and here's
what it's meant to me and here's how you
can incorporate it into your life.
It's like people are absolutely starving
for that or dying of thirst for them.
This connects with what you earlier said
about the curriculum,
the,
that the old way of teaching the
humanities was in that manner.
Uh,
as objects of love.
This is what I have loved what previous
generations have loved to and handed
onto me.
Hey,
try it out and you will love it too.
Whereas the postmodern curriculum is a
curriculum of hatred.
It's,
it's a,
uh,
directed against a cultural inheritance.
One after another.
The work separated before us,
stripped naked and thrashed,
you know,
uh,
um,
by what,
by revealing whatever ideology will
power structure is being concealed
within them.
And that's,
of course there's not why they were
written and it's not how they should be
understood.
It's not why they survived.
Exactly either.
But like this is the best that the best
of us could produce and it's nothing.
Why should you bother?
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And it means that students who go
through that curriculum come out with a
sentence of the hopelessness of
everything and thus are successfully
educated by postmodernist standards.
Yeah,
yeah.
I suppose that's right.
But,
um,
you know,
there's no reason why one should,
one should accept this one.
Oh,
all good things begin,
uh,
in the,
in small areas because,
because two or three people,
uh,
you know,
well,
it's Christ said two or three are
gathered my name there am I with you,
but at the same as it is an old couch,
right activities,
it's perhaps a friendship will,
will,
uh,
will be gay.
It will start up a reading group and
after that reading group,
there'll be others come in gradually if
it's founded on love of the thing that's
being studied and offered,
he will always try and fit in the long
run over this negativity.
The problem is the negativity is
subsidized.
It's subsidized by universities who are
paid for by governments who are paid for
by tax payers and so on.
Uh,
and the,
the answer is to take away those
subsidies and,
uh,
and deprived of education completely of
money.
And it will be back with us again.
I suppose I suggested something like
that in public in Canada not so long
ago,
to cut the budgets of the universities
across the board by 25 percent and let
them sort themselves out because,
but the,
the no subsidy idea at least forces
those who provide education to do it
purely on its merits and the fact that
these counterproductive disciplines,
let's say have been subsidized for so
long,
has given them a power that's far,
far outstrips their,
their credibility and their
attractiveness.
Right
now.
I wanted to,
to
point out a,
it will this,
this,
this chat may be seen by a few people
online at some point and draw attention
to the vet that we're all wearing
poppies to,
of course,
is a,
is a symbol of respect and memory for an
inheritance of our own past,
uh,
for the,
the suffering
that has given us or at least protected
and given us so much that we hold dear.
I'd like to ask you both about memory
and the inheritance of the past and,
and what it means to have a pedagogy of
what it means to have a pedagogy of the
transcendent,
uh,
in relation to our past.
How do you open open those,
those,
those doorways,
and perhaps,
uh,
if,
if the spirit moves you to a speak about
works that you love,
that you've been able to open up to
others.
One of the reasons for remembering in
the way that we remember the armistice
in the first world war,
one of the reasons is,
is gratitude and gratitude is in short
supply in our societies today.
And,
um,
it's the,
it's the greatest gift that we can offer
in fact,
sorts of people who are dead because,
uh,
what else can we do,
except to acknowledge what their
sacrifice.
So,
um,
I think that gratitude is a fundamental
part of memory.
Um,
there are,
of course,
accumulations of guilts and so on.
Uh,
and those are being emphasized all the
time in the postmodern and curriculum,
all the,
all the ways in which we are not
entitled to our inheritance.
But I think in the face at that,
we have to insist on the ways that we
are entitled to that inheritance.
If people have died for it,
for,
for our sake,
know that isn't a fantastic title that
we enjoy and we should feel grateful to
them for that.
I mean,
when it comes to actual works of art or
whatever,
which have opened the sense of the depth
of one's own inheritance.
That I think is a very interesting
question.
There's so many of them,
but,
but just to mention only one,
I'm the Bach B minor mass.
To me,
that's a door into the,
into the,
the whole,
uh,
the whole European inheritance going
back to the crucifixion.
There it is.
There,
it all is encapsulated in music,
music of celebrating the universal
claims or the Roman Catholic church,
but written by a Protestant,
you know,
that it's,
um,
and offered as a gift to mankind,
narratives and those such things.
So transcend any,
any minor historical details,
uh,
that to unrecognized is that,
that is what the past really is for one,
that great depth of,
uh,
of inheritance that can't be enumerated,
but just enjoy it.
Just to follow up before we turn to
Jordan.
Roger,
at the beginning you talked about how
great literature,
great writing is writing in which the
reader finds himself,
finds herself.
I'm taking box mass in b minor.
Um,
you've,
you've spoken about the unfolding of the
self that is found in these great works
are the reflection of the self,
I know,
or at least I think you've written about
the unfolding of the theme,
uh,
in,
in of that mass in particular,
but certainly in other,
other of your writings,
the unfolding of the theme and music.
Could you say something about the.
I know that's a huge question,
but the way in which the unfolding of
the theme in music is an unfolding of
the self.
So really,
um,
provocative way of putting it.
It is true that when you listen to a
theme,
uh,
in music,
you are not listening to a sequence of
notes.
Something begins in that first note and
injures to the final node and it goes on
all the way through,
even though there are spells of silence,
it's still going on in the silence so
that our ability to hear something as a
theme is already a contribution that we
make.
It comes out of us.
So we've identified with that movement.
That movement is,
it's there in the world because it's
there in us,
but,
but in so many ways,
all our inner life is interrupted and
unfulfilled and it's full of things that
start up.
And then Peter around,
uh,
and I think that is one of the
fundamental experiences of human beings,
that there's an inner disorder that
things never actually come to a
conclusion.
But here uniquely movements begin and
come to a conclusion.
This is a.
and that conclusion is,
is complete,
is that satisfaction of,
of,
uh,
of the,
um,
unsaturated nature of the movement of
the first beginning,
the,
uh,
and it's an,
an experience.
What,
why do we value that?
I think we value,
I value it in the same way as you battle
your tragedy because it gives
completion.
And closure to things that otherwise
wouldn't ever have them
and things that are transient as well
because it does have a beginning and an
end and the end doesn't invalidate the
utility of the,
of the entity.
That's right.
So in the gratitude,
I mean that was the,
that was exactly the theme that sprung
to mind for me as soon as you asked that
question.
I mean,
one of the things that I find profoundly
disquieting about the modern radical.
Oh,
uh,
what would you call it?
An ideology that is so.
No,
so unfortunately dominant on campuses
among young people is that it's
unbelievably ungrateful.
And when I,
when I walk outside and there's not a
riot and death in the streets,
I'm having a good day.
That's my sense of history.
It's like I'm constantly staggered by
the fact that so much works all the
time.
It's absolutely.
I met this guy a while back and he'd
been in a motorcycle accident.
He really got hurt,
man.
He was,
he was pretty much half destroyed and he
worked as a telephone lineman.
He worked with this guy who had
Parkinson's disease who had was equally
destroyed in a slightly different way
and the two of them together could climb
up a telephone pole and continue their
job,
and I thought this unbelievable
infrastructure we have that is just an
absolute bloody ongoing ongoing miracle
is sustained by people exactly like
that.
You know,
they're having very difficult lives and
a country like Canada.
They go out in the middle of the bloody
winter where you die,
it's frigid and something breaks and
they fix it and the lights are on.
The lights are on all the time and I
come to somewhere like Europe and to me
it's an absolutely overwhelming
experience to see king's chapel today,
to wander around the city.
I'm just staggered that people produce
this and so amazed that we could do it
and so grateful that it exists.
We're talking about king's chapel.
The people who started didn't live to
see its completion.
They were.
They were driven by this nobility of
transcendent vision and they produce
these enduring forms and out of the
bloody misery of history.
We've erected all this spectacular
infrastructure that we're so fortunate
to be part of and there none of that
gratitude is taught and it's partly not
taught because people have no sense of
the absolute catastrophe of history.
I mean for me the hobbs.
It's like nasty,
brutish and short that the simplest and
most likely social circumstances,
catastrophe punctuated by hell and to
see that not happening in a sustained
manner constantly and to see things
improving around us and and to be
reliable in that manner and then not to
be grateful for that.
It's like it's an unbelievable
combination of ignorance and willful
ignorance in gratitude and willful
blindness and it does no one soul any
good.
It's so good to walk down the streets of
a beautiful town like this and to be
open mouth in northern Iran,
amazement at what's here and so and to
not instill that sense and young people,
for them to understand that they are
standing on the bones of generations of
people who suffered to make this
possible despite all their errors and
have brought this forward.
It's like,
yeah,
Whoa,
whoa.
This is a very a salutary lesson.
Actually,
because he did look into the abyss and
stepped back from it and reported on it
and as did shows,
it's in and um,
we postwar baby boomers to haven't had
that experience.
I had a little glimpse of it in the old
communist days,
but we only saw the edge of it then,
you know,
um,
but,
uh,
still the sense,
the sense that it is,
they're always beneath your feet and
the,
and the crust is thin as it can be in
certain places.
That I think is something that young
people do need to be taught without
making them get gloomy about it,
but to recognize that they're lucky.
Okay.
Last question before we open up for a
few questions here.
It seems to me that the backward looking
that we've talked about,
or you had a wonderful phrase,
a wide eyed open mouthed at non-ironic
in amazement,
I think you said walking around this
transcendently beautiful town of
Cambridge,
which houses this August and ancient and
beautiful institution.
I'm
with.
You mentioned Jordan.
We're seeing the king's chapel earlier
today,
that those who started the work knew
they wouldn't be those who would finish.
And those who finished knew they had
inherited to work,
they had not themselves begun.
And so I suppose I want to ask,
um,
we've talked about the,
the,
the necessity to turn back with
gratitude to the past,
to our inherited a past.
I want to talk also about the
possibility of,
of building and a creation.
Uh,
these chapels and buildings were built
at some time.
You,
yourself are a composer.
Both of you are authors of books that
many,
many people have,
uh,
found depth and truth in.
So I want to,
uh,
to ask about,
the possibilities for,
for,
for renaissance,
for rebuilding or building a new and new
buildings and new forms of community,
new forms of art.
Perhaps new buildings have old forms of
architecture,
new colleges and universities,
a new,
more healthy and beautiful forms of,
of courtship,
new forms of a flourishing arts and
music.
Uh,
it seems to me so important that,
that we not lose sight of the fact that
precisely the abiding truth of the
transcendent in us,
it gives us hope to,
to answer that call.
Yeah.
It must be the case that when,
when describing our cultural
inheritance,
we're not just describing something
that's gone,
we must be describing something of which
we are still a part a and which,
which has to changed as we are changing
to accommodate us.
And all this was said by Elliot in
tradition and the individual talent,
you know,
that,
um,
that the artist must be constantly
trying to say that new thing that he
came into the world to say,
but he can only say it if he adapts his
style to the,
the inheritance of the tradition,
thereby transforming the tradition and
transforming himself.
And we all were there and there is no
formula for doing this because the
formula is precisely what destroys the
creative act.
But we have to assume that new things
will come and they will come through,
uh,
as,
as they always did in the past through
fasting and prayer
and the occasional glass of wine.
My kids,
Jordan.
Well,
we could concentrate,
I suppose,
on building the future instead of
criticizing the past.
I mean,
it's necessary to decompose to
reconstruct those.
Those acts can't be separated,
but the decomposition is the
prerequisite for the reconstruction and
you know what I've been recommending to
people is that they start on whatever
scale they can start on with whatever's
in front of them because they have more
in front of them.
Then they think these,
these,
these circumscribed areas that these
small places that people can call their
own,
even if it's only their room,
you can start to do something creative
and beautiful there.
I mean,
I've suggested to people that they start
by putting the room in order and that
that implies a purpose.
It's like,
well,
your room is somewhere that you exist.
It's,
it's,
it's a place that surrounds you,
that tells you how to be is put it in
order so at least it isn't screaming
chaos at you in a soul destroying
manner.
Make it pristine and,
and,
and orderly and in a fashion that suits
what you're aiming at.
So have an aim and then this is perhaps
a chapter in my next book.
Well,
maybe you start by putting your room in
order and then you make it beautiful and
then you learn how to make something
beautiful and to make something
beautiful is to make it worthwhile and
to participate in that transcendent,
in that transcendence.
Maybe you need one
certainly and for your future self,
which is also others.
You know,
this idea that people are fat even of,
of,
of self gratification.
Let's say as an antidote to nihilism
will take your pleasure in the moment.
It doesn't even work for you because
you're stuck with you tomorrow and you
next week and so even to treat yourself
properly is to treat yourself as part of
an ongoing community.
But I would say start by you start in
the world.
If you have some wisdom and some
humility by taking the potential that
lies dormant in front of you and
interacting with it in the logos like
manner with truth and with love,
and by transforming that potential into
whatever you can create out of it,
that's good and and even if it's,
it won't be small.
If you do that,
you can transform your whole household
by transforming your room.
You can transform your whole
neighborhood by transforming your house
like these things spread very,
very rapidly and that is right there in
front of you.
You know,
and people think they're impoverished
now that they don't have any opportunity
and that opportunity is hidden from them
by their,
by their unwillingness to take the steps
that are necessary to put what they
could put in front of them in order and,
and,
and to,
and to produce the beauty instead of the
ugliness where they could do that.
And I don't think there is anything more
powerful than that that works.
I've had thousands of people tell me
that it works.
You know,
personally come and talk to me every day
now on the street and say,
my life was in terrible disorder.
I had no vision.
I wasn't abiding by the truth.
My relationships were fragmented.
I've decided to make something of
myself,
whatever that might be.
I've decided to adopt more
responsibility to tell the truth and
things are in comparatively better.
And so that's,
that's there for everyone to take,
and regardless of your circumstances,
and I know that some people have what
appeared to be larger opportunities and
more privileged in front of them,
but that also makes their commensurate
moral responsibility larger.
So there's certain balancing
that's a natural consequence of that.
So now recognizing the nature of the
finite,
there's a train one of us needs to
catch,
are going to have to draw this
conversation to a close,
but not before.
We've all had a chance to thank both of
you for everything you do to fan the
flames of the transcendent for your
readers,
for your listeners,
for all of us.
Thank you very much.
Both of you.